Caitlyn Jenner now there's something
different about you but I I can't I
can't put my finger in it
[Applause]
Caitlin I don't
know after her surgery so now they can
pay her 20 less
if you can I really respect this guy I
think I think he's brilliant what he's
done what he's a cop he's had three
different careers that's great but I
want to strangle him you want to say
I did well I mean yeah but maybe you
would do Rambo and then he would do
commando commando yeah
laughs
I was playing with the Orlando Magic and
the Bulls and Michael Jordan they swept
us he grabbed me and he told me a quote
that I would never forget before you
succeed you must first learn to fail
when Michael Jordan told me that quote
before you succeed you must first name
he didn't tell you you want to be in
Kazam too
a long time I'm not saying how old she
is but her driver's license says for
covered wagons only
I don't know why they say things like
that you're in the prime of Life only it
takes you a little longer to get primed
you got as much sex appeal as a handful
of lotion
and I know you got a vibrator with a can
opener on it
[Applause]
it was wonderful in that Dwayne's got a
tattoo right above his ass that says
come on
George Clooney married Amal Alamuddin
this year Amal is a human rights lawyer
who worked on the Enron case was an
advisor to Kofi Annan regarding Syria
and was selected for a three-person U.N
commission investigating rules of War
violations in the Gaza Strip so tonight
her husband is getting a Lifetime
Achievement Award
thank you
what is the thing that you're most proud
of in your career oh Evan Almighty of
course it's a good movie that's a good
movie [__] you fatty Steve I'm not just
lead me right into that and smack me
across it's a great movie okay
regardless of all that they go like it
lost a lot of money and all that stuff
no one saw it and the budget was way
over and no one was interested in seeing
it it's a great movie so you is the best
at foot you know so you get Posh so does
Sporty Spice go out with someone from
scunthup you know
oh what do you mean that's my friend and
she's lovely exactly why is he trying to
say scum Fork it's not a good thing
[Applause]
to say about
it I forgot to thank you Dean for the
candle and the wine that you sent to my
room but you forgot to send up a girl
that's what you forgot I I figured it
you're
you're just sliding The Candlewood wear
you out
this Corel not your last name not
originally
what is it Pinocchio
okay
like when you go to the beach and
someone yells
shark shark
and then they just realized that it's
Steve Carell doing the backstroke
you're a poor man's Mike Myers
if I was on a desert island and I had a
choice between eating a wahlburger and
it
a raw dead fish
following the dead fish
Nikki is what's known as a dirty
comedian and I don't mean a material I
mean she hasn't washed the [__] since
Memorial Day
I had no clue I was dark until I got
here I got to America and I met some
people and I'm like he said you black I
said what's we are black he said no you
black as [__]
that's what the [__] you mean one guy
told me I look like under the bed oh no
yo have you look under the bed it's dark
as [__] under the bed they told me I
look like I have no bright ideas
they said the difference between me and
midnight is 11 59. shut up man she just
said when God said let there be light I
was out of town
they told me I have to wear white gloves
before I eat chocolate
I don't bite my [__] fingers they
told me every time I take a [__] I think
my dick fell off
not like this somebody told me Stevie
Wonder they told me Stevie Wonder sees
me every day that's dark as [__] that
[__] don't see [__] really do
dogs have such a part in Betty's life
it's really her whole life for instance
when I propose to her the first thing
she said was that sit up and bake
she wouldn't even accept my ring until I
rolled over and played dead and then on
our honeymoon she rolled over and played
dead
[Music]
when you go to the beach and you swim
out past the buoys do people think that
there's an island there I'm not that fat
percentage of body fat versus your
percentage of how much your nose weighs
I guarantee that your nose per capita
weighs more than what I would all right
[__] you Fatso Jennifer Lawrence made
the news when she demanded equal pay for
women in Hollywood and she received yeah
overwhelming support from
people everywhere
there were marches on the street with
nurses and Factory workers saying how
the hell can a 25 year old live on 52
million this is
there were plumbers around the world
going poor girl in town we're lucky now
so and I just don't feel like we're
gonna accomplish that when he's showing
more cleavage than Britney and I are
then show more cleavage yeah I'm good
thank you okay well so am I but I'm not
showing any cleavage this is a t-shirt
I'm surprised because normally you could
like braid your chest hair
tell her to stop picking on me please
don't pick on him he's a kind man who's
never insulted anyone
uh Zendaya's here from Euphoria hello
Zendaya
Zendaya just turned 26 last week happy
birthday happy birthday uh 26 is a weird
age in Hollywood I mean you're young
enough to play a high school student but
you're too old to date Leonardo DiCaprio
[Applause]
Nick Cannon did that song used to look
up to you and he said that was about you
dick riding I would never respond
no let's look now look look the camera's
on right he's a legendary corny the only
thing that makes him look corny is this
rapping yeah I don't know why he's so
passionate about it like what the hell
is going on bro look you suck bro
you suck bro I'ma just tell you the
truth like there's never a moment where
you said something and we was like oh
bars
you play a lot of uh people that are
kind of uh Nazi haters which is weird to
me why do you say that because you look
like Hitler's dream
the thing is the Benedict that everyone
sees is a little different to the
benediction the real Benedict is like
he talks like that and it's very
ungainly and he's not it's what I call
dyspraxic which means he can't dance and
he can't sort of like physically moves
himself but you switch a camera on the
guy he becomes this super sexy live
Sherlock super intelligent it's like cut
and it's like was that any good and
you're like I've Benedict because
someone's going to see that and they're
gonna know so what after a take what
Benedict will be shepherded into a small
room and he's just kept there and we
tell him he's there for you know I just
stay there Ben we'll be out we're all
going to have dinner and stuff and he
just sits there like playing with his
like you know we've got a little toy
that's like a Rubik's Cube but it's
simpler it's like a four it's like four
not six